Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Some of those who have been with Justinian at the palace late at night, men who were pure of spirit, thought they saw a strange, demoniac form taking his place.
感谢您收听《过往皆历史》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《过往皆历史》。想要获取加更节目、抢先收听、无广告畅听并进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistory.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。某些曾在深夜陪伴查士丁尼在宫殿里的人，那些灵魂纯洁的人，认为他们看到了一种奇怪的、恶魔般的形态取代了他。
One man said that the emperor suddenly rose from his throne and walked about, and indeed he was never one to remain sitting for long. And immediately Justinian's head vanished, while the rest of his body seemed to ebb and flow, whereat the beholder stood aghast and fearful, wondering if his eyes were deceiving him. But presently he perceived the vanished head filling out and joining the body again, as strangely as it had left it. So Tom Holland, that is the historian Procopius talking of the Emperor Justinian, the 6th century emperor of what was then what they would have called the Roman Empire, what we often call the Byzantine Empire. Do you think Justinian,
有一个人说，这位皇帝突然从王座上站起来四处走动，事实上他从来都不是一个能坐很久的人。紧接着，查士丁尼的头消失了，而他身体的其他部分似乎在涨落，当时旁观者惊恐万分，怀疑自己的眼睛是不是看错了。但随后他发觉那消失的头颅重新充盈起来，并像它离开时那样诡异地重新连回了身体上。那么，汤姆·霍兰，那是历史学家普罗科匹乌斯在谈论查士丁尼皇帝，这位 6 世纪的皇帝，统治着当时他们称之为罗马帝国、而我们经常称之为拜占庭帝国的地方。你认为查士丁尼，
two questions, do you think he was a demon? And do you think his head was capable of leaving the body and reappearing on the body afterwards well i mean the two questions are kind of interconnected aren't they well you could be a demon and not have that power i suppose well i think it's unlikely i think if you're a demon you can definitely do that um and there's a he goes on to say doesn't he that um there's another person who comes to justinian looks into his face and the whole of the face melts and becomes a featureless lump of flesh and then gradually the features come back on that's right the face changed into a shapeless
两个问题，你认为他是个恶魔吗？你认为他的头能够离开身体，随后又重新长在身体上吗？嗯，我的意思是这两个问题某种程度上是相互关联的，不是吗？好吧，你可以是一个恶魔但没有那种能力，我想。嗯，我觉得这不太可能，我觉得如果你是个恶魔，你绝对能做到这一点。嗯，而且他接着说，对吧，嗯，还有另一个人来到查士丁尼面前，看着他的面孔，整张脸都融化了，变成了一个没有五官的肉团，然后五官又逐渐长了回来。没错，那张脸变成了一个没有眉毛也没有眼睛长在正确位置的无定形
mass of flesh with neither eyebrows nor eyes in their proper places very disturbing and then what Procopius then goes on to say is that I myself did not witness this but I spoke to people who definitely saw it, which I don't know. So Justinian, of course, becomes the great lawgiver in Roman history. He compiles this enormous corpus of Roman law, all the kind of the decrees and dictates from the new Rome, Constantinople, and from the old Rome, going all the way back to the days of the Republic. And I suspect that Procopius' evidence would not stand up in court when measured against the splendor and gravity of Justinian's own law code. But we will come to this, won't we, at the end of this episode, because this is part two of an episode on not just Justinian, but also Theodora. That's right. We talked about their rise to power
肉团，非常令人不安。然后普罗科匹乌斯接着说，我自己没有亲眼目睹这一幕，但我跟那些确实看到了的人谈过，虽然我不知道。所以，查士丁尼当然成了罗马历史上伟大的立法者。他编纂了庞大的罗马法大全，涵盖了来自新罗马君士坦丁堡以及老罗马的所有法令与指示，一直追溯到共和国时期。我怀疑普罗科匹乌斯证词在面对查士丁尼法典的宏伟与庄严时，在法庭上是经不起推敲的。但我们会在本集节目结束时讨论这个，不是吗，因为这是关于查士丁尼以及狄奥多拉的双集节目的第二部分。没错。我们在第一集里谈到了他们的崛起
in the first episode and if you haven't listened to that, you probably should. So we've got to the spring of the year 527. Justinian who is from this Balkan background, comes from what is now North Macedonia originally.
在第一集里，如果你还没听过，大概应该去听听。所以我们来到了公元 527 年的春天。查士丁尼有着巴尔干背景，原本来自现在的北马其顿。
His uncle, Justin, had been emperor. Justinian has succeeded him and his wife theodora the circus performer acrobat um dancer prostitute kind of courtesan turned empress um and she's in her 20s he's in his 40s and they have this tremendous project to rebuild the glory of rome don't they tom they absolutely do so just Justinian basically has two mission statements, so two goals, one of which is to see the Roman Empire restored to its former dignity. So by this point, the western half of what had originally been the Roman Empire has gone. So Britain, obviously,
他的叔叔查士曾经是皇帝。查士丁尼继位了，他的妻子狄奥多拉——这位马戏团表演者、杂技演员、嗯，舞女、妓女、某种交际花转变为的皇后，嗯，她二十多岁，他四十多岁。他们有一个宏伟的项目，要重塑罗马的辉煌，对吧，汤姆？确实如此。所以查士丁尼基本上有两个使命宣言，也就是两个目标，其中之一就是让罗马帝国恢复其昔日的尊严。因此到这个时候，原本属于罗马帝国的西半部分已经消失了。所以不列颠，显然，
Gaul, Spain, Italy, africa and justinian dreams of getting them back but the other thing that he dreams of is seeing heaven established on earth he's a very very devout christian and essentially the two the two ambitions are not entirely disconnected because he sees the uh the power and the splendor and the might of the roman empire as being expressive of god's plans for the whole of humanity um so if he can if he can win god's favor if he can reorder the roman empire to reflect the will of god then god's favor will descend on the empire and hopefully before you know it the legions will be back in britain and it's another thing that binds them tom um his belief in the dignity and the importance of the office of emperor and of central control and central power. this sort of centrifugal process where bits were breaking off, where authority was being
高卢、西班牙、意大利、非洲，查士丁尼梦想着把它们夺回来。但他梦想的另一件事是看到天堂在人间建立。他是一个非常非常虔诚的基督徒，基本上这两个雄心并不是完全脱节的，因为他将罗马帝国的力量、宏伟和强大视为上帝对全人类计划的表达。所以如果他能赢得上帝的青睐，如果他能重组罗马帝国以反映上帝的意志，那么上帝的青睐就会降临到帝国身上，希望用不了多久，军团就会重返不列颠。这也是维系他们关系的另一件事，汤姆，他对皇帝职位和中央控制、中央集权的尊严与重要性的信念。这种离心过程，即各个部分正在分裂，权威正受到
challenged and authority passing to local warlords and things who end up becoming in the long run kings of kingdoms. And a lot of Justinian's projects, it seems to me, is about reasserting Constantinople's control, whether it be in religion, or indeed, you talked about law, reforming the laws, or physical control over italy and um north africa and so on and don't you think that's a lot of it so that when he when he thinks about heaven on earth as you as you put it that's the rule of god or christ isn't it the rule of the one deity and and the the idea of the rule of one emperor and the rule of one god i mean they're kind of the same thing to him aren't they don't
挑战，权威正转移到地方军阀等手中，他们最终在长期来看成为了各个王国的国王。在我看来，查士丁尼的许多项目都是为了重申君士坦丁堡的控制权，无论是对宗教的控制，还是你谈到的法律——改革法律，或者是对意大利和北非等的实际控制。你不认为这占很大比重吗？所以当他想到人间的天堂时，正如你所说的那样，那是上帝或基督的统治，不是吗？独一神明的统治，以及独一皇帝统治和独一上帝统治的想法，我的意思是，对她而言这基本上是一回事，你不这么
you think well uh except that of course the the emperor does not control the church um but he likes the patriarch the patriarch of constantinople is much more under his thumb obviously than the bishop of romes say uh or or even the patriarch of of um the pope in alexandria but even the patriarch in constantinople is a figure whose responsibility to God is of a different order to the emperors. So I think that Justinian does absolutely see himself appointed by God to serve as the shield and defender of the church. And he undoubtedly sees himself as set there, set on earth to bring unity to the church. And Justinian is very, very proud of himself as a kind of theologian. He likes to get churchmen in and then berate them
认为吗？嗯……不过当然，皇帝并不控制教会。但他喜欢让君士坦丁堡牧首比罗马主教——比如说，甚至亚历山大港的教皇或牧首——更加听从他的摆布。但即使是君士坦丁堡的牧首，其对上帝的责任也是不同于皇帝的。所以我认为查士丁尼绝对觉得自己是被上帝任命为教会的保护者和捍卫者的。他无疑认为自己被安置在世上是为了给教会带来统一。查士丁尼对身为神学家的自己感到非常非常自豪。他喜欢把神职人员叫来，然后训斥他们，
and kind of lecture them. And he definitely, you know, he sees it as his duty to stamp out heresy. He sees it as his duty to do all that he can to close down the remaining strongholds of pagan philosophy. So Justinian is notorious as the figure who closes down supposedly the Platonic school in Athens, which in fact, the truth is rather different. This isn't the Platonic school. The Platonic school had been been destroyed long long before back in the first century bc um so but but there this is a school that had been set up in the fourth century it's it's not really platonic it's no platonic it's very mystic it's kind of weird it's full of you know it's this is not a kind of stronghold of greek rationalism or anything like that um and what what justinian does he doesn't actually ban it but he stops kind of central
并对他们长篇大论。他绝对（你知道的）认为铲除异端是自己的职责。他认为尽其所能关闭希腊哲学仅存的据点是自己的职责。因此，查士丁尼作为一个据称关闭了雅典柏拉图学园的人物而闻名，但事实上，真相却相当不同。这不是柏拉图学园。柏拉图学园早在公元前一世纪就被摧毁了很久很久以前……所以，但这是一个在四世纪建立的学园，它其实不是柏拉图式的，一点也不柏拉图，它非常神秘，有点奇怪，充满了（你知道的），这根本不是什么希腊理性的据点之类的东西。而且查士丁尼所做的，他其实并没有禁止它，但他停止了中央
funding funding from the government um and philosophical schools do remain in well in alexandria for instance places like that so so that it kind of ticks along but the the writing is on the wall for that kind of philosophical tradition um and as i say he's he's very very brutal in stamping at heresy so there's an obsession with coherence and order absolute coherence and he sees it as his duty to do this and one one of the kind of the um the measures of this is that there's um there's a kind of calendar and um one of the ornaments for this calendar is the heads of heretics on spikes oh nice which is kind of like an ad friend calendar is that the calendar you get from a Chinese restaurant or something?
政府的资助。哲学学园在比如亚历山大港等地方确实还存在，所以它勉强维持着，但这种哲学传统的丧失已成定局。而且正如我所说，他在铲除异端方面非常非常残酷。所以有一种对连贯性和秩序的执念，绝对的连贯性，他认为这是自己的职责。而衡量这一点的一个标准是，有一种日历，这种日历的一个装饰是刺在长矛上的异端头颅。哦，太棒了，这有点像基督徒的倒计时日历吗？那是你在中餐馆什么的能拿到的日历吗？
That kind of thing, yeah. I mean, he sees that as part of his duty. But also, of course, we mentioned in the first part that there's this kind of division within the emperor between the Chalcedonians, who are the Orthodox Christians, and Monophysites, who are centered much more in Alexandria and Egypt and other parts of the Levant. And, of course, Theodora is a monophysite yeah so there's a sense in which i think that their relationship is you know he's he is saying you know he's saying you know by treasuring theodora so much by promoting her so high he is kind of saying to the monophysites, you know, you are still Christian. You know, you are still kind of beloved as I love Theodora. So that's a part of it. But in the other areas that you mentioned, so law particularly, and military conquest,
诸如此类吧，是的。我的意思是，他认为这是他职责的一部分。但当然，正如我们在第一部分中提到的，皇帝内部存在着一种分裂，即正统基督徒卡尔西顿派，与主要集中在亚历山大港、埃及以及累范特其他地方的基督一性论派。而且，狄奥多拉当然是个基督一性论派。是的，所以从某种意义上说，我认为他们的关系是……（你知道的）他是在说……（你知道的）通过如此珍视狄奥多拉，通过将她提拔得如此之高，他实际上是在对基督一性论派说：“你知道的，你们依然是基督徒。你知道的，你们依然像我爱狄奥多拉那样被爱着。”所以这是其中的一部分。但在你提到的其他领域，特别是法律和军事征服方面，
absolutely, Justinian sees himself as appointed by God. There's one other element I want to ask your opinion about. So we talked in the first episode about Rome's great rival. I mean, by far Rome's biggest rival, which is Persia. So throughout the 6th century, Rome is facing a different kind of Persian Empire than the one that it had faced a couple of generations earlier. So a much more self-confident, much more coherent, it's the Sasanian dynasty that are running the Persian empire. And at the same time, Justinian's reign is almost exactly kind of coincidental with that of a guy called
毫无疑问，查士丁尼认为自己是由上帝任命的。还有另一个要素我想听听你的看法。我们在第一集里谈到了罗马的劲敌。我的意思是，罗马最大的劲敌，非波斯莫属。所以在整个 6 世纪，罗马面对的是一种不同于几代人之前的那种波斯帝国。这是一个更加自信、更加连贯的波斯帝国，萨珊王朝正在统治波斯帝国。与此同时，查士丁尼的统治几乎与波斯的一个名叫
Khosrow in Persia, who is himself a centralizer, a massive reformer, really beefing up the power of the kind of Persian monarchy in the Persian state. And there are some historians on there who say, well, what Justinian is doing is basically an attempt to kind of tool up the Roman Empire so that it can properly compete with its big Persian rival. How much do you think that's true, Tom? You're right that Khosrow is the great rival of Justinian and might even have been his brother. Because Khosrow's father, Kaved, a very formidable figure, had kind of repaired the Persian Empire after it had been shattered by a Hunnic invasion, really put it back together. But had then signed up to a kind of radical form of Zoroastrianism.
库思老的人的统治完全同步。库思老本人也是一个中央集权者、一个巨大的改革者，真正大大增强了波斯君主制和波斯国的力量。有些历史学家认为，查士丁尼所做的事情基本上是试图武装罗马帝国，以便能够与他强大的波斯劲敌更好地竞争。汤姆，你认为这有多大程度是真实的？你说得对，库思老是查士丁尼的强劲对手，甚至可能是他的兄弟。因为库思老的父亲卡瓦德是一个非常令人生畏的人物，在波斯帝国被匈人入侵粉碎后，他修复了波斯帝国，真正将其重新拼凑了起来。但后来却接受了一种激进形式的祆教（琐罗亚斯德教）。
Zoroastrianism is the state religion of Iran, of Persia. There was a kind of proto-communism, which is kind of interesting combination and absolute monarchy in the form of Khavad and this kind of communist form of millenarianism. But Khosrow was much more orthodox and therefore the Mazdakites, as these communists were called, these kind of proto-communists were called, didn't want him to succeed. But Khosrow was Khavad's favorite son. So it all becomes kind of very complicated. And Khavad has this wheeze that perhaps one way to secure Khosrow's succession is to have him adopted by Justin. But obviously, the problem with that is that Khosrow might then end up inheriting the Roman Empire as well.
祆教是伊朗、波斯的国教。当时存在着某种原始共产主义，这是一种有趣的组合，即卡瓦德形式的绝对君主制与这种共产主义式的千禧年主义。但库思老更加正统，因此马兹达克派（这些共产主义者被称为这个名字，这些所谓的原始共产主义者）不希望他继位。但库思老是卡瓦德最喜爱的儿子。所以这一切变得非常复杂。卡瓦德有一个诡计，也许确保库思老继位的途径之一就是让他被查士这么收养。但显而易见，那样做的问题在于库思老最终可能也会继承罗马帝国。
So that gets put on the back burner. But there is this sense, I think, that Khazra and Justinian are, you know, they're heavyweights who have matched up together. And the fact that there is this fraternal quality, you know, it's Cain and Abel. You know, these are Jacob and Esau, Romulus and Remus. These are people who are so alike that they're almost destined to go to war. But the real problem for Justinian, I think, is that no matter how many bribes he chucks the Persians away to kind of sign peace treaties, no matter how much he beefs up the defenses along the Syrian frontier, of course, you know, people will know from the way that the Islamic State just crossed over from Syria into Iraq,
所以这件事被搁置了。但我认为有一种感觉，即库思老和查士丁尼是重量级人物，他们旗鼓相当。而且这种兄弟般特质的事实（你知道的），这是该隐和亚伯。你知道的，这是雅各和以扫，罗慕路斯和雷穆斯。这些人是如此相似，以至于他们几乎注定要开战。但对查士丁尼来说真正的难题，我认为，无论他向波斯人抛出多少贿赂来签署和平条约，无论他在叙利亚边境沿线加强了多少防御，当然，（你知道的）人们会从伊斯兰国刚刚从叙利亚穿境进入伊拉克的这种方式中了解到，
that there are very few natural features here. And so essentially, the Roman defenses are dependent on a certain number of very strong kind of fortifications. But he knows that if he starts launching campaigns in the West, he's almost guaranteed to have the Persians come calling in the East. So that really is the problem problem and that is why prior to justinian since the fall of rome and that the the the collapse of direct roman rule over italy and north africa that's really why there haven't been any sustained attempts to get them back but here's an interesting counter argument to that tom um i i agree with that the rome faces i mean what people will now call byzantine but what we're calling rome that's called the new rome yeah constantinople is facing a huge sort of geopolitical dilemma which is it wants to read you know it has it seizes these commitments in the west these ideological commitments i suppose
这里几乎没有什么天然地貌。因此本质上，罗马的防御依赖于数量有限的非常坚固的防御工事。但他知道，如果他在西方发动战役，他几乎可以肯定波斯人会在东方找上门来。所以这确实是个难题，这也是为什么在查士丁尼之前，自从罗马沦陷以及罗马对意大利和北非的直接统治崩溃以来，真正没有任何持久的尝试去夺回它们。但这里有一个有趣的相反论点，汤姆，我同意这一点，即罗马面临着——我的意思是，人们现在称之为拜占庭，但我们称之为罗马的那里，被称为新罗马，对吧，君士坦丁堡面临着一个巨大的地缘政治困境，即它想要重新（你知道的）它在西方承担了这些承诺，我想是意识形态上的承诺，
but it also has the the pressure of persia its great superpower rival in the east but my old i mean i'm going to quote my old tutor um peter saris who um the great historian of the sixth century yeah who we mentioned in in our in our episode on disease exactly he argues that one of the things that so of course previous emperors had quite fancied the idea of reconquering the west but he argues that one of the things that really drove Justinian to want to do it is that he really needs those resources of Italy, of North Africa, of Spain, ideally, because he needs to kind of tool up for that war again, for fighting the Persians. That basically Justinian needs to take command of the kind of Mediterranean sea lanes. He needs to get taxes and resources flooding in. Because ultimately, Tom, this might surprise some listeners. Rome, in many ways, is the weaker of the two superpowers,
但它也面临着东方伟大的超级大国对手波斯的压力。不过我的老导师——我的意思是，我要引用我的老导师彼得·萨里斯的话，他是 6 世纪的伟大历史学家，我们在关于疾病的那集里提到过他——他认为，当然，前几位皇帝曾非常喜欢重新征服西方的想法，但他认为真正驱使查士丁尼想要这样做的原因之一是，他非常需要意大利、北非、最好还有西班牙的资源，因为他需要为那场战争、为与波斯人作战重新武装自己。基本上，查士丁尼需要控制地中海的海上航线。他需要让税收和资源如潮水般涌入。因为归根结底，汤姆，这可能会让一些听众感到惊讶。在许多方面，罗马其实是两个超级大国中较弱的一个，
wouldn't you say? I mean, the Romans have never really... I'm not sure I would say that. I mean, well, here's evidence that it might be the weaker. So in 531, so within four years of becoming emperor, Justinian is paying the Persians £11,000 in gold a year not to attack him. Now, if you're the person paying that tribute, I mean, you'd rather be the person receiving the tribute than the person paying it, wouldn't you? But the Romans have been doing this continuously. But the reason they can do it is they can afford it. So in a sense, if a strong economy is the basis of strength, then by that measure, it's the Romans. Well, another way of looking at that, Tom, would be to say that it's the sort of fat, effete, weak party that is paying the lean, hungry, militarily powerful party to go away. I think that's to buy into an understanding of empires that may well be reflective of kind of traditional Greek or Roman approaches to it.
你难道不这么认为吗？我的意思是，罗马人从来没有真正……我不确定我是否会这么说。我的意思是，好吧，有证据表明它可能较弱：所以在 531 年，即成为皇帝的四年内，查士丁尼每年向波斯人支付 11,000 英镑的黄金，以求他们不攻击他。现在，如果你是支付这笔朝贡的人，我的意思是，你宁愿是接收朝贡的人，也不愿是支付它的人，对吧？但罗马人一直在这样做。不过他们能这样做的原因是他们支付得起。所以从某种意义上说，如果强大的经济是力量的基础，那么按照这个标准，就是罗马人。好吧，汤姆，看待这一点的另一种方式是说，这是一个臃肿、衰弱、软弱的一方，花钱让精干、饥饿、军事力量强大的一方走开。我认为这是接受了一种对帝国的理解，这很可能反映了传统希腊或罗马的方法。
But Anastasius, who we mentioned in the previous one, the accountant turned emperor, he has set the Roman economy on such firm footings. That it can do that. That it can afford to do that. that so it's justinian is spending money to keep cuz row happy yeah so that he can start preparing for a war against the goths and the vandals in the west so you don't see him doing the west in order because he is anxious about the east as it were i think that's a part of it but i think i think it's much more that he has a sense that it is the destiny of r, God ordained to eternal victory is the phrase. Right. You know, wonderful book by Michael McCormack,
但阿纳斯塔修斯——我们在前一集中提到过的那位由会计转任的皇帝，他为罗马经济奠定了如此坚实的基础。以至于它能够做到这一点。它能够负担得起这样做。所以查士丁尼花钱是为了让库思老高兴，好让他能够开始准备对西方的哥特人和汪达尔人发动战争。所以你并没有看到他为了西方而发起战争，是因为他像人们所说的那样对东方感到焦虑。我认为这是其中的一部分，但我认为更多的是因为他有一种感觉，即这是罗马的命运，上帝注定获得永恒胜利，这就是这句话。没错。你知道的，迈克尔·麦考密克的精彩著作，
Eternal Victory, about how the Romans see the world in the time of Justinian. He sees it as predestined, but he's aware that there are huge, huge problems of which Persia is the largest. So essentially, he's trying to buy Persia off so that he can then launch this return, which is something that Roman aristocrats in the West as well are dreaming of. So by the time of Justinian, you're starting to get piracy across the Mediterranean, which is something the Romans haven't had to deal with since the time of Pompey the Great back in the first century BC.
《永恒的胜利》，讲述了在查士丁尼时代罗马人如何看待世界。他认为这是命中注定的，但他意识到存在着巨大无比的问题，其中波斯是最大的问题。因此本质上，他试图花钱买通波斯，以便随后能够发动这场回归，这也是西方罗马贵族同样梦寐以求的事情。所以在查士丁尼时代，地中海开始出现海盗活动，这是自公元前一世纪伟大统帅庞培时代以来罗马人再也没有应对过的问题。
So this is seen as a kind of humiliation. And so there's this vision of an armed prince, you know, that the land and the sea will kind of quake before his approach, that Rome's dormant navies will once again command the shipping lanes. This is part of the kind of the propaganda that has been swirling around ever since the collapse of Rome. And part of justinian's whole all his plans these great plans he's had is that he wants to he basically wants to become that
所以这被视为一种羞辱。因此出现了一种全副武装的君主的愿景（你知道的），土地和海洋将在他的逼近面前颤抖，罗马沉睡的海军将再次统领航运路线。这是自罗马崩溃以来一直在流传的宣传的一部分。查士丁尼的所有计划、他所拥有的这些宏伟计划的一部分是，他基本上想成为那种
kind of puissant caesar yeah returning to the mastery of the sea and the land well i mean there's no doubt tom that he that he's he's well equipped to do that he's called a coin matos the sleepless one because he works all day he's great with paper i mean he's a tough man he wouldn't be emperor if he hadn't he wouldn't have got to the top um if he wasn't but he obviously works tremendously hard but he also needs money i mean this is the constant issue for roman emperors isn't it they need money so right from the start when he comes in at 527 he has two guys in particular john of cappadocia um who's a the sort of tax man par excellence, who I think introduces 26 new taxes in a couple of years. Makes him immensely popular.
强大的凯撒，重返对海洋和陆地的统治。好吧，我的意思是毫无疑问，汤姆，他完全有能力做到这一点。他被称为“科马托斯”（Comatos），即不眠之人，因为他整天工作，他很擅长处理文件。我的意思是，他是个硬汉，如果他不是这样的话，他就不会成为皇帝，如果他不是这样的话，他就不会登上巅峰。但他显然工作极其努力，不过他也需要钱。我的意思是，这是罗马皇帝面临的常青问题，不是吗？他们需要钱。所以从他 527 年上任的一开始，他就有两个特别的人，卡帕多西亚的约翰，这位卓越的税务官，我认为他在几年内推出了 26 种新税。这让他极其受欢迎。
And a guy called Trebonian who's in charge of reforming the laws, basically gathering all the laws together and sort of finally codifying this great mass of rules and regulations that's left over from centuries of Roman civilization. But the taxes in particular are obviously very unpopular. They're an attempt to, again, to assert central control over the periphery. But not just the periphery, not just the periphery. So also over the Senate. Yeah. over the senate yeah so so one of the you know we in the first part we talked about how one of the ways in which constantinople is the is is the second rome the new rome is that it does have a senate exactly as the original rome had had but justinian is such a kind of autocratic figure
还有一个叫特罗布尼亚努斯的人负责改革法律，基本上是将所有法律收集在一起，并对几个世纪罗马文明遗留下来的一大堆规章制度进行最后的编纂。但税收显然非常不受欢迎。这是再次试图对边缘地区建立中央控制。但不仅仅是边缘地区，不仅仅是边缘地区。还有对元老院的控制。是的，对元老院的控制。所以在第一部分中，我们谈到了君士坦丁堡作为第二罗马、新罗马的方式之一，就是它确实拥有一个与原版罗马一模一样元老院，但查士丁尼是一个极具专制色彩的人物，
that he's impatient with that as many of the you know the earlier caesars had been so procopius in his in his secret history the one that we've been reading from, he compares Justinian to Domitian, who is one of the traditional tyrants of Rome, one of Suetonius' 12 Caesars. He says that Justinian looked just like Domitian. It's basically like saying to your political rival, you look just like Adolf Hitler. It's just ridiculous. But it's very pointed because Domitian was much hated by the Senate for the way that he bullied them. He executed them. He put them in the shadow. He refused them to do their stuff. He kind of rubbed their noses in the fact that they were politically impotent. And Justinian is doing the same. So the fact that you have people within Constantinople who are unhappy about the growing tax rate,
以至于他对此感到不耐烦，就像许多早期的凯撒一样。因此，普罗科匹厄斯在其《秘史》中——也就是我们一直在读的那本书——他将查士丁尼比作图密善，图密善是罗马传统的暴君之一，是苏维托尼乌斯笔下的十二凯撒之一。他说查士丁尼长得跟图密善一模一样。这基本上就像对你的政治对手说，你长得跟阿道夫·希特勒一模一样。这简直荒谬。但这个比喻非常尖锐，因为图密善因欺凌元老院而饱受元老院的恨意。他处决了他们。他让他们黯然失色。他不让他们做自己的事。他用事实狠狠羞辱了他们，让他们在政治上无能为力。而查士丁尼也在做同样的事。因此，君士坦丁堡内部有人对不断上涨的税率感到不满，
and you have senators who are very, very unhappy about the kind of autocratic ways of Justinian. So one of the things that Justinian and Theodora both do is they say that anyone who comes into their presence, rather than just kind of crooking the knee gently, as had previously been the formula, they have to kneel down and they have to kiss the slipper or the hem of the robe. Well, this is all about the dignity of the office again, isn't it? But this is something new. I mean, this is a conscious kind of repudiation of the inheritance of Rome, if you like, because that inheritance from the distant Republic before the time of Augustus, when Rome had been a community of citizens. Romans continued to see themselves as citizens, but Justinian repudiates that. He sees them as subjects. And this is something that
同时元老院议员对查士丁尼的独裁作风也非常非常不满。因此，查士丁尼和狄奥多拉共同做的一件事就是，他们规定任何来到他们面前的人，不再像以前那样仅仅微微屈膝，而是必须跪下，必须亲吻拖鞋或长袍的下摆。嗯，这又全是为了维护职位的尊严，不是吗？但这是一种新事物。我的意思是，这是一种有意识地对罗马传统的抛弃，如果你愿意这么说的话，因为自遥远的共和国时代、奥古斯都时代之前——当时罗马是一个公民共同体——以来的传统。罗马人继续将自己视为公民，但查士丁尼抛弃了这一点。他将他们视为臣民。而这是
lots of people in Constantinople don't like. Well, Tom, just before we set that up, long-time listeners to this podcast will be struck by the resemblance between this and a debate that we had in a podcast on Alexander theander the great but alexander introducing the persian custom of proskinesis and people you know exchanging kisses with them and stuff and it's a not dissimilar issue is it that isn't it the idea of a of an autocrat trying to get people to pay homage to him to publicly abase themselves against and people who think of themselves as having this sort of civic virtue that means they can't do it i think the difference is is that alexander is consciously adopting a foreign practice yeah um justinian sees himself as being
君士坦丁堡的许多人所不喜欢的事。汤姆，在我们开始之前，这个播客的老听众一定会注意到，这与我们在关于亚历山大大帝的播客中讨论过的一场辩论非常相似，当时亚历山大引入了波斯式的跪拜礼（proskinesis），人们与他们交换亲吻之类的。这是一个非常相似的问题，不是吗？这就是一个独裁者试图让人向他致敬、公开卑躬屈膝的想法，而那些认为自己拥有某种公民美德、因而不能这样做的人……我认为区别在于，亚历山大是有意识地采用一种外国习俗。是的，而查士丁尼认为自己是
true to the inheritance of of roman custom so he sees as caesar he sees himself as the heir of constantine and ultimately of augustus but chiefly of Constantine, that he is kind of God's anointed. That's what he's been put on earth for. But of course, his aim is also to restore Rome to its former greatness. But the very way that he is trying to restore Rome involves crushing huge amounts of what makes the second Rome still Roman. So the dignity of the Senate, the status of the people of Constantinople and beyond as citizens. I can see, Tom, that in this argument,
忠于罗马习俗的传承的。因此作为凯撒，他视自己为君士坦丁大帝的继承人，并最终成为奥古斯都的继承人，但主要是君士坦丁大帝的继承人，他是上帝的受膏者。这就是他被放到世上的原因。但当然，他的目标也是恢复罗马昔日的伟大。然而，他试图恢复罗马的方式本身，却涉及到摧毁大量使第二罗马依然具有罗马特色的东西。比如元老院的尊严，君士坦丁堡及其他地方人民作为公民的地位。汤姆，我看得出来，在这场争论中，
you and I would be on very opposite sides. So which side do you think? I think Justinian did it and he was right. Yeah, I would be on the other side. Of course you would, because you're a Ciceronian, aren't you? Yeah, I would be. I would be. Anyway, listen, all of this brings us to the beginning of the year 532.
你我将站在截然相反的立场上。那么你觉得哪一边对？我认为查士丁尼做了，而且他是对的。是的，我会站在另一边。你当然会，因为你是个西塞罗主义者，不是吗？对，我会的。我确实会。不管怎样，听着，所有这一切把我们带到了公元532年的年初。
So Justin has been in power for, what, five years? He's started his great reform programs. He hasn't yet started his reconquest of the West. He's clearly itching to do. It's January. It's probably quite cloudy, kind of cool day. Everybody's looking forward to a great day out at the Hippodrome. The blues and the greens are all tanked up,
所以查士丁尼已经掌权大约五年了？他开始了伟大的改革计划。他还没有开始对西方的收复失地运动。他显然渴望这么做。现在是1月。可能是一个多云、有点凉爽的日子。每个人都期待着在赛马场度过美好的一天。蓝色党和绿色党都喝足了酒，
ready for a great day out. And it all goes horribly wrong, doesn't it? And we'll find out what happens at the Hippodrome after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
准备迎接美好的一天。结果一切都大错特错了，不是吗？我们将会在中场休息后揭晓赛马场发生了什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The date is the 10th of January, 532. We are in Constantinople in the Hippodrome. The stands are packed. Everybody's looking forward to a great day of sport. Tom Holland, what happens next? Great day of sport and a great day of rioting because, of course, for the rival factions, the Blues and the Greens,
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史就是一切》（The Rest Is History）。今天是公元532年1月10日。我们在君士坦丁堡的赛马场。看台座无虚席。每个人都期待着精彩的一天。汤姆·霍兰德，接下来发生了什么？精彩的体育比赛和精彩的暴动，因为对于蓝色党和绿色党这两个敌对派系来说，
the chance to have a punch up is a crucial part of the entertainment. And the Blues and the Greens all start piling into each other. There's a riot, various bits of infrastructure outside the Hippodrome
有机会大打出手是娱乐活动至关重要的一部分。蓝色党和绿色党开始互相群殴。发生了一场暴乱，赛马场外的各种基础设施
catch fire. Justinian sends the troops in to crack heads and restore law and order um the ringleaders get arrested and these these ringleaders are both blues and greens and the following day they are they are hanged i think there are eight of them is that right is that about eight of them yeah so they're about eight of them and six of them all goes well they all die well not not well for them yeah but for justinian and you're very much on the side of justinian yeah
着火了。查士丁尼派军队去镇压并恢复法律和秩序，闹事头目被捕，这些闹事头目既有蓝色党的也有绿色党的，第二天他们就被绞死了，我想大概有八个人，是吗？大约有八个人，对吧？所以大约有八个人，其中六个人……一切顺利，他们都死了——好吧，对他们来说不太顺利，但对查士丁尼来说……你非常支持查士丁尼，对吧？
he did it and he was right to do it but uh two of them the rope snaps and one of these lucky people is a blue and one of them is a green and they kind of get bundled up by monks don't they and taken across the bosphorus to a monastery on the other side where they, or church, and there they're able to claim sanctuary. And so then there's an issue of what happens, what's going to happen next. And pressure grows on Justinian
他做了，而且他做得对，但是其中有两人的绳子断了，其中一个幸运儿是蓝色党的，另一个是绿色党的，他们被修士们裹挟着带过了博斯普鲁斯海峡，到了另一边的一座修道院里——或者是教堂，在那里他们得以寻求庇护。于是接下来就出现了一个问题：会发生什么？接下来会发生什么？施加给查士丁尼的压力越来越大，
to issue a pardon. And on the 14th of January, Justinian comes to the Hippodrome, takes his seat, and announces that he's not going to pardon them. And Dominic, what is the result of that? Does this go down well? The crowd goes absolutely mental, doesn't it?
要求他发布特赦令。1月14日，查士丁尼来到赛马场，就座后宣布他不会特赦他们。多米尼克，结果是什么？这事结果好吗？人群彻底疯了，不是吗？
I mean, people just start roaring and shouting. And clearly there's been some orchestration, I would say. And we were talking before the break about the sort of disquiet of people who don't like Justinian's new taxes. They probably don't like the fact that he is expecting greater public obedience and self-abnegation to him and to Theodora. There are probably lots of people actually who regard them as parvenues, aren't there?
我的意思是，人们开始咆哮和尖叫。显然这是经过精心策划的，我想是的。我们在中场休息前谈到过那些对查士丁尼的新税收感到不满的人的不安情绪。他们可能不喜欢这样一个事实：他期望公众对他和狄奥多拉表现出更大的服从和自我牺牲。实际上可能还有很多人认为他们是暴发户，不是吗？
Who think, oh, he's just some Vulcan peasant and she's an ex-prostitute. What are we doing? Among the Senate, definitely. These ghastly people. So there's probably an element of that. And there's also clearly an element of the crowd being, you know, tanked up and enjoying a punch-up and stuff. And so the crowd start chanting at him. They go berserk and they start chanting as one famously,
他们会想，哼，他不过是个巴尔干农民，她是个前妓女。我们在搞什么鬼？元老院里的人绝对是这么想的。这些讨厌的家伙。所以其中可能含有这种成分。而且显然也有这样一种成分，即人群喝了酒，喜欢打架斗殴之类的东西。于是人群开始对他高呼口号。他们彻底疯狂了，开始齐声高呼那句著名的口号，
Nika, Nika, or Nika, Nika, depending on your pronunciation, which basically means victory, victory, or conquer, conquer, which is, I guess, which is what they would have chanted anyway. Am I right, Tom? During the races? Yes. And, but also what, you know, the one that wins, then they, they do the chanting and heart. So half the crowd will chant it and half won't. Yeah. Because that, you know, half is, half is back the side that's won, half is back the side that's lost. The thing that is unbelievably ominous and must have been completely terrifying for justinian is that now the whole hippodrome is
“尼卡，尼卡”（Nika, Nika），取决于你的发音，这基本上意味着胜利、胜利，或者征服、征服，我想，这也是他们无论如何都会高呼的口号。我说得对吗，汤姆？在比赛期间？是的。而且，你知道，获胜的一方，然后他们就会高呼并……所以半边人群会高呼，半边不会。因为你知道，一半人支持获胜的一方，一半人支持失败的一方。令人难以置信的不祥预兆、对查士丁尼来说一定极其恐怖的是，现在整个赛马场都在
chanting this and they're doing it as unison and it becomes obvious to him that the greens and the blues have teamed up and they all spill out of the um of the hippodrome and basically they they start disassembling the center of of constantinople so burning they burn and so so we mentioned so hagia sophia the great cathedral of constantinople goes up in flames the augustaeon which is the kind of the great uh open space next to hagia sophia and that the chalke the the bronze gates that lead into the palace that goes up in flames um the baths of zypzipas go up in flames so that's the baths that had all the classical statuary so it's a bit like the british museum going up in flames i mean everything just gets lost and
高呼这个口号，而且他们是齐声高呼，这让他清楚地意识到绿色党和蓝色党已经联合起来了，他们从赛马场蜂拥而出，基本上开始拆毁君士坦丁堡的中心，进行焚烧——所以我们提到过的圣索菲亚大教堂，君士坦丁堡的大教堂化为灰烬；奥古斯塔翁广场（Augustaeon），也就是圣索菲亚大教堂旁边的那个巨大开阔空间；通往宫殿的青铜大门（Chalke）化为灰烬；泽齐普斯浴场（Baths of Zeuxippus）化为灰烬，那是拥有所有古典雕塑的浴场，所以这有点像大英博物馆付之一炬，我的意思是，一切都化为乌有，
basically it's absolute carnage and justinian tries to kind of reimpose order so he sends in i think about about 1500 troops and they they're able to kind of stabilize the situation so that the palace itself is not under threat but they can't bring central constantinople back under order and it just gets worse and worse and worse and worse yes five days five days before he goes back to the hippodrome to address the crowd and at this point he's been reduced basically to begging so he says i'll you know if you please go home i'll give you an amnesty you know there'll be a free pardon and they howl him down at this point and at this point tom now you mentioned and i think in the previous episode that there was
基本上这就是一场彻底的大屠杀。查士丁尼试图恢复秩序，所以他派出了大约1500名军队，他们能够稳定局势，使得皇宫本身没有受到威胁，但他们无法让君士坦丁堡市中心恢复秩序，局势变得越来越糟。是的，五天。在他回到赛马场向人群发表讲话的前五天，此时他基本上已经被逼到只能恳求了，所以他说：“如果你们回家，我会给你们大赦，会有无罪释放。”而此时他们对他发出嘘声。汤姆，你刚才提到，我在前一集里说过，
somebody else who could have been emperor um who was called hypat, who had been a commander away on the frontiers. And the nephew of Anastasius. And he's quite old. But at this point, he reemerges as a significant figure because some of the crowds say he's the man we want as emperor. I mean, this is not unprecedented, right, for crowds to go berserk and to call for new emperors. And, you know, if you lose the support of the army and of the palace guard,
还有另一个人可以当皇帝，名叫希帕蒂乌斯（Hypatius），他曾是一名远在边境的指挥官。他是阿纳斯塔修斯的侄子。他年纪挺大了。但此时，他又作为一个重要人物重新出现，因为一些民众说他正是我们想要当皇帝的人。我的意思是，这并非没有先例，对吧，民众疯狂起来并呼吁拥立新皇帝。而且，如果你失去了军队和宫廷卫队的支援，
then you're toast, basically. That must be the fear that Justinian has at this point. Yeah. I mean, Hypatius doesn't, I think, want to be emperor at all. He really doesn't, particularly because he knows that if Justinian succeeds in restabilizing everything, then he's absolute toast. But it doesn't matter. The, the, the, the crowds pick him up. They hail him as emperor and the destruction continues. And Justinian is very anxious by this point, whether he can trust anyone, whether he can trust his soldiers, whether he can trust his officials. And he starts to contemplate flight.
那么你基本上就完蛋了。这一定是查士丁尼此时感到的恐惧。是的。我的意思是，希帕蒂乌斯根本不想当皇帝。他真的不想，尤其是因为他知道，如果查士丁尼成功恢复了秩序，那么他自己就彻底死定了。但这没关系。民众拥戴了他。他们高呼他为皇帝，破坏仍在继续。此时查士丁尼非常焦虑，不知道自己还能信任谁，能否信任他的士兵，能否信任他的官员。他开始考虑逃跑。
So he orders ships to, to be prepared. So, you know, cause there uh harbors in the palace so he could escape from that way and it is at this point that theodora shows her metal probably the most famous contribution to history apart from that business with the geese tom um would you like me to read theodora's, what Theodora says? I would love you to, yeah. She says, every man who is born into the light of day must sooner or later die. And how could an emperor ever allow himself to be a fugitive? May I myself never willingly shed my imperial robes, nor see the day when I am no longer addressed by my title. If you, my lord, wish to save your skin, well, you will have no difficulty in
所以他命令备好船只。因为皇宫里有港口，他可以从那里逃跑。正是在这个时候，狄奥多拉展现了她的气魄，这可能是除了跟大鹅有关的那档子事之外，对历史最著名的贡献了，汤姆，你愿意让我读一读狄奥多拉说的话吗？我很乐意，请吧。她说：“凡是降生于日光之下的男子，迟早都免不了死。一个皇帝怎么能容许自己成为逃亡者？愿我永远不被迫脱下皇袍，也永远不要看到我不再被称为陛下那一天的到来。如果陛下你想保全性命，
doing so. We're rich. There is the sea. There are our ships. But consider first whether when you reach safety, you will not regret that you did not choose death in preference. As for me, I stand by the ancient saying, the purple is the noblest winding sheet. Iron lady. Is that how you imagine Theodora speaking to him? But to a degree, of course. So Theodora is very keen to crush the enemy within. She is. She's facing rioters. She's facing strikers. And so what are you going to do in that situation? You're going to recruit new platoons of police which is basically basically what justinian is shamed by this kind of iron resolve and um a whole load of troops conveniently do turn up one is uh under the command of a barbarian from the danube called
那是轻而易举的事。我们很富有。那里有大海，那里有我们的船只。但请先想一想，当你到达安全地带时，你是否会后悔自己没有选择死亡。至于我，我坚守那句古老的格言：紫袍是最崇高的寿衣。”铁娘子。这就是你想象中狄奥多拉对他说的话吗？当然在某种程度上是这样的。所以狄奥多拉非常热衷于消灭内部的敌人。她是这样的。她面临着暴徒，她面临着罢工者。那么在这种情况下你要做什么？你要招募新的警察部队，这基本上就是——查士丁尼被这种钢铁般的决心羞辱了，而且
amundus yeah so he has he has a load of crap troops fortunately they're available in constantinople and the other is under the command of a very famous figure, probably Justinian's most famous general, the hero of a novel by Robert Graves, Belisarius. And these troops get kind of, you know, rather like Mrs. Thatcher getting the police, getting the Met to go and break the strike in Nottingham. Justinian and Theodora mass these troops and send them into the Hippodrome. And by this point, Justinian has kind of reactivated his link with the Blues and has said,
一大批军队恰好出现了，其中一支由来自多瑙河的蛮族统帅带领，名叫蒙杜斯（Mundus），是的，他有一支精锐部队，幸运的是他们在君士坦丁堡随时待命；另一支军队由一位非常著名的人物统帅，可能是查士丁尼最著名的将军、罗伯特·格雷夫斯小说中的英雄贝利撒留。这些军队被集结起来，有点像撒切尔夫人调动警察、让伦敦警察厅去诺丁汉镇压罢工一样。查士丁尼和狄奥多拉将这些军队集结起来，派往赛马场。此时，查士丁尼已经重新恢复了与蓝色党的联系，并表示：
you know, watch out, guys. You don't want to die and defend the Greens. So most of the Blues by this point, if not all, but most have left the Hippodrome. So you've got the Greens, you've got a few stragglers. they're all unarmed they're in the hippodrome and mundus's troops come in one end balaceres has come in the other yeah and they just kind of cut their way through and they slaughter everybody in their path and actually one person you haven't mentioned tom for those who get out there are more troops waiting outside under the command of somebody
你知道的，小心点，伙计们。你们可不想为了保卫绿党而死。所以到这个时候，大部分蓝党，如果不是全部的话，但大多数人已经离开了赛马场。所以绿党还在，还有一些零星的人。他们都没带武器，都在赛马场里，蒙杜斯的军队从一端冲进来，贝利撒留从另一端冲进来，是的，他们就这样一路砍杀，屠杀他们路径上的所有人。汤姆，其实你漏掉了一个人，对于那些逃出去的人来说，还有更多军队在某个人的指挥下在外面等着
called narses oh i forgot narses narses who was one of the eunuchs wasn't he in our troops waiting outside under the command of somebody called Narcisse. Oh, I forgot Narcisse. How could you forget Narcisse, Tom? Who was one of the eunuchs, wasn't he? Our 10 top eunuchs. So newcomers to the podcast will be delighted to hear we have an episode about the top 10 eunuchs in history. And Narcisse is probably the top Armenian eunuch in history. He's of Armenian descent.
叫纳尔塞斯。噢，我忘了纳尔塞斯。纳尔塞斯，他不是那些阉人之一吗？我们的军队在外面等着，由一个叫纳尔塞斯的人指挥。噢，我忘了纳尔塞斯。汤姆，你怎么能忘了纳尔塞斯？他不是那些阉人之一吗？我们十大顶尖阉人。所以播客的新听众会很高兴听到我们有一集关于历史上十大阉人的节目。而纳尔塞斯可能是历史上最顶尖的亚美尼亚阉人。他有亚美尼亚血统。
Yeah. He's about, I mean, we talked about we compared justin with joe biden i mean i think narses makes joe biden look positively youthful because narses is about 140 isn't he but he's he's a tremendous i mean he's a tremendously impressive man yeah and very loyal to justinian and if you if you listened in the first part you may remember that justin at this point who justinian's predecessor uncle, he becomes emperor because he gets given large amounts of gold to go out and bribe people to support one of the pretenders. And Justin just pockets the gold. So Narcisse is given gold by Justinian to go and do the same. But Narcisse, unlike Justin, stays loyal and true.
是的。他大概，我的意思是，我们之前讨论过，我们把查士丁尼和乔·拜登作对比，我的意思是，我觉得纳尔塞斯让乔·拜登显得非常年轻，因为纳尔塞斯大概有140岁了吧，但他是一个了不起的——我的意思是，他是一个极其令人印象深刻的人，而且对查士丁尼非常忠诚。如果你听了第一部分，你可能还记得查士丁尼在这一时期——当时查士丁尼的前任叔叔，他成为皇帝是因为得到了大量黄金去收买人们支持某个竞争者。而查士丁尼把黄金据为己有。所以查士丁尼给纳尔塞斯黄金让他去做同样的事。但纳尔塞斯与查士丁尼不同，他依然保持着忠诚和正直。
And he goes out and he bribes all the various ringleaders. He bribes the various senators to calm down. And this is what kind of precedes the ability of Belisarius and Mundus to slaughter everyone in the Hippodrome. That's not a bad choice for Narcisse. I mean, Narcisse has a tremendous life, doesn't he? He does, yes. I mean, he has a great career, as we shall see. Well, Mundus and Belisarius do. They all do, yeah.
他出去收买各个派系的领头人。他收买各个参议员让他们冷静下来。而这正是贝利撒留和蒙杜斯得以屠杀赛马场内所有人的前提。对于纳尔塞斯来说，这倒是个不错的选择。我的意思是，纳尔塞斯度过了精彩的一生，不是吗？确实是的。我的意思是，正如我们将会看到的，他有着伟大的职业生涯。嗯，蒙杜斯和贝利撒留也是。他们都有，是的。
Right. So they've killed all the rioters or those who were were left but they're left with a smoking smoldering capital city basically shall i read you what john the lydian said about it i'd love to hear what john and the lydian said the city was a series of blackened blasted hills like the reaches of a volcano uninhabitable because of dust smoke and the foul stench of building materials reduced to ashes and presumably tens of thousands of bodies. 50,000, according to Procopius. Yeah. So if we're saying, you know,
对。所以他们杀光了暴徒或那些留下的人，但他们留下的基本上是一个冒烟、烧焦的首都。要不我读一下约翰·利迪斯对它的评价？我很想听听约翰·利迪斯的评价：“这座城市是一系列被熏黑、炸毁的山丘，就像火山的边缘，由于尘土、烟雾以及建筑材料化为灰烬的恶臭而无法居住，据普罗科皮乌斯记载，还有数万具尸体。5万具。”是的。所以如果我们说，
the population of Constantinople is half a million, that's a tenth of the city. Yes. Not the first time there'll be lots of dead bodies in the streets of Constantinople. So a tenth of the population perhaps slaughtered. I mean, maybe an exaggeration, probably an exaggeration, but still enormous numbers of casualties and the whole of central Constantinople wiped out.
君士坦丁堡的人口是五十万，那这就是城市人口的十分之一。是的。这不会是君士坦丁堡街头第一次出现大量尸体。所以大概有十分之一的人口被屠杀。我的意思是，也许有点夸张，很可能是夸张，但仍然是极其庞大的伤亡人数，整个君士坦丁堡的中部都被摧毁了。
But there's good news for Justinian in that as well, because he's got a lot of people that he didn't like. Plus, he can rebuild the city now as he wants. He can create the imperial city of, you know, you talked about him wanting heaven on earth. He can create heaven on earth in one building in particular. Yes. he can create heaven on earth in in one building in particular yes so hagia sophia the cathedral has burnt down and the new building the new hagia sophia starts to rise from the ashes like a phoenix um very very rapidly after the um after the riots which suggests that that justinian had already
但对查士丁尼来说这也是个好消息，因为他除掉了许多他不喜欢的人。此外，他现在可以按自己的意愿重建这座城市。他可以创造帝国的城市，你知道的，你之前说过他想要人间天堂。他可以在一栋特定的建筑里创造人间天堂。是的，他可以在一栋特定的建筑里创造人间天堂。是的，所以圣索菲亚大教堂被烧毁了，新的建筑，新的圣索菲亚大教堂像凤凰一样从灰烬中升起，在暴乱发生后非常非常迅速地拔地而起，这表明查士丁尼其实已经
been planning it probably uh so that is that is one example of the way in which the Nica riots actually end up redounding hugely to his benefit. The other, of course, is that, as you said, he's been able to get rid of a lot of his enemies. So quite a lot of the senators, they get disinherited, sent into exile. Poor Hypatius gets executed. Yeah, he never even wanted to be emperor, the poor fellow. No, no, very sad. But more importantly, the institutional power of the Senate is now massively, massively diminished. And so everything that Justinian wanted for his role as emperor has basically been consolidated. And this is one of the paradoxes of Justinian's reign, is that this man who is ruthlessly, monomaniacally obsessed with restoring the Roman Empire to its former grandeur,
在策划这事了，可能吧。所以，这就是尼卡暴动最终给他带来巨大好处的一个例子。另一个例子当然是，正如你所说，他得以摆脱了许多敌人。因此相当多的参议员被剥夺继承权并流放。可怜的希帕蒂乌斯被处决了。是的，这个可怜的家伙甚至从来没想过当皇帝。不，不，非常悲伤。但更重要的是，参议院的体制权力现在被极大地、极大地削弱了。因此，查士丁尼作为皇帝所追求的一切基本上都得到了巩固。这也是查士丁尼统治的悖论之一，这个冷酷无情、近乎病态地执着于恢复罗马帝国昔日辉煌的人，
does so much to destroy elements within the new Rome that derived from the old Rome. And so the Nicorites play a key role in the process by which Constantinople becomes that much less Roman, even as Justinian sees himself legitimately as the kind of archetype of a traditional all-conquering triumphant Caesar. And I think that that is the paradox that in a sense structures his whole reign. It structures the wars that he will very soon be launching westwards to retake Italy and North Africa. And I think that that's a note on which we should end this episode. I agree. But just before we do that, Tom, Hagia Sophia. So he builds the Hagia Sophia. I mean, you must have been to this many times. For me, the building that Justinian,
却做了那么多事情来摧毁新罗马内部承袭自旧罗马的元素。因此，尼卡暴动在君士坦丁堡变得不再那么“罗马”这一进程中起到了关键作用，尽管查士丁尼本人合法地将自己视为传统的、征服一切的凯旋凯撒的某种原型。我认为正是这种悖论构成了他整个统治的结构。它构成了他不久后向西进军收复意大利和北非的战争结构。我认为我们应该以此结束本期节目。我同意。但在我们这么做之前，汤姆，圣索菲亚大教堂。所以他建造了圣索菲亚大教堂。我的意思是，你一定去过很多次。对我来说，查士丁尼建造的建筑——
well, it wasn't Justinian, was it? It was Anthemius of Trales and Isidore of Miletus. With this colossal dome, you can see it right, you can see it to this day in Istanbul. And to me, there is nothing, I mean, maybe the mosaics of Justinian and Theodore in Ravenna, but there is nothing that better captures the grandeur and the might of the Eastern Roman Empire, this empire that Gibbon wrote off as this sort of pitiful relic, corrupt relic. I mean, to me, to go into the hagia sophia i always find it just the most transcendent experience yeah it's the building that more than anything else i think
好吧，其实不是查士丁尼，对吧？那是特拉勒斯的安特谟斯和米利都的伊西多尔。凭借这巨大的穹顶，你今天在伊斯坦布尔还能亲眼看到它。对我来说，没有什么——也许除了拉文纳的查士丁尼和西奥多拉的马赛克镶嵌画——没有什么比这更能体现东罗马帝国的宏伟与力量了，这个被吉本贬低为可怜的、腐败的残余的帝国。对我来说，走进圣索菲亚大教堂总是让我感到最超然的体验。是的，这栋建筑比其他任何东西都更能
serves as the embodiment of of constantinople of the byzantine empire because on the one hand of course it stands in a line of descent from the original rome so the dome is a Roman invention developed from the volcanic ash, actually, that had been spewed up by Vesuvius, developed by Nero, developed famously by Hadrian with the Pantheon in Rome. And this vast dome, the largest dome ever built, when it was raised, it's the ultimate triumph of Roman engineering. But at the same time, of course, it is, unlike the Pantheon, it's built as a church to the glory of God. And when Justinian goes in, it is said, he cries out, I have triumphed over you, Solomon. Solomon, I have surpassed thee. But of course, Solomon, neither Solomon nor Justinian, Tom, had ever recorded a podcast.
作为君士坦丁堡、作为拜占庭帝国的化身，因为一方面，它当然承袭自最初的罗马的正统脉络——这个穹顶是一项罗马发明，实际上是从维苏威火山喷发出的火山灰中发展而来的，由尼禄发展，并由哈德良在罗马的万神殿将其发扬光大。而这个巨大的穹顶，建成时是建造史上最大的穹顶，是罗马工程学的最终凯异。但与此同时，当然，与万神殿不同，它是作为一座荣耀上帝的教堂建造的。当查士丁尼走进去时，据说他大喊：“我战胜了你，所罗门！所罗门，我超越了你。”当然，汤姆，无论是所罗门还是查士丁尼，从来都没有录制过播客。
So they had not yet ascended to the heights of human ingenuity and achievement as we have there's a note on which to end this episode on that note on that bombshell we will recap this was meant to be one episode by the way we've just finished episode two we will reconvene next time for episode three where we will be talking about the reign of justinian theodora justinian's wars um the we'll be reflecting on the plague of Justinian, which we touched on last, well, I was going to say last time, but several times ago with Karl Harper, when we talked about disease and the end of the Roman Empire. And I suppose, Tom, we'll also be talking about Justinian and Theodora's legacy, the way they've been remembered,
所以他们还没有达到人类才智和成就的高度，就像我们在这里所做的那样。这就是结束本期节目的一个注脚。带着这个重磅消息，我们将进行回顾。顺便说一句，这本来应该是一期节目，我们刚刚完成了第二集，我们将在下一集第三集中再次聚首，届时我们将讨论查士丁尼的统治、西奥多拉、查士丁尼的战争，嗯，我们还将反思查士丁尼大瘟疫——我们上次提到过，哦，我本想说上一次，但其实是跟卡尔·哈珀聊疾病与罗马帝国终结时提到了好几次。我想，汤姆，我们还会讨论查士丁尼和西奥多拉的遗产，他们被铭记的方式，
and the way we think about Rome and Byzantium. And we'll be talking about Procopius' secret history, where that is coming from, how accurate the account of Theodora and the geese and Justinian's face turning into a featureless lump of flesh. So a lot more demons. There will be a lot more of Tom's special brand of gymnastics next time. See you then. Bye-bye. See you then. Bye-bye. See you then. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
以及我们对罗马和拜占庭的看法。我们还将讨论普罗科皮乌斯的《秘史》，它的来源是什么，关于西奥多拉和大雁以及查士丁尼的脸变成无特征肉块的记载有多准确。所以会有更多恶魔。下次还会看到更多汤姆标志性的体操表演。到时候见。拜拜。到时候见。拜拜。到时候见。拜拜。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需收听独家节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和优先购买现场门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。即 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。